According to Aristotle, objects all fall at a constant speed, and that speed depends
on their weight, and when Aristotle says "constant speed," what he means is that
the instant you release the ball, it's already traveling at the same speed that it will hit the ground.
Okay. So, objects fall at constant speed and that speed is proportional to the mass.
Now, what does this mean—speed proportional to mass?
It means that if you double the mass of an object you double the speed.
If you triple the mass, you triple the speed.
We can write this proportionality with this funny-looking symbol here.
In fact, she looks a little bit like the alpha we saw in the first unit.
Now, we can use this proportional relationships to make mathematical calculations.
Let's say we have two objects, a one-kilogram and a two-kilogram mass.
If this falls with a certain speed S1, this one will follow the speed S2.
The way we can use this proportionality relationship to a make calculation
is in the following line.
We say that the ratio of speed S1 to S2 is equal to the ratio of the masses,
and we can say that because they are proportional.
In this simple example, I just want you to tell me,
if S1 is 2 meters per second and these are the masses, what is S2?
Well, we can just plug in here.